but this llama phobia Islam if I may say
he's not one of the guys he brought on
he comes up with this ridiculous idea
that Islamophobia you know it was
invented by the Muslim Brotherhood right
yeah and actually the term started as
you may or may not know it started with
the Muslim Brotherhood in a very smart
strategy and it's just this term so that
no one's allowed to criticize Islam and
that's not the point you go to any
university you know in America and
there's articles Curtis you know
criticizing Islam or whatever it is
right but it's done in a respectful
academic manner it's not done in a
hostile manner there's a difference
between that this idea of Islamophobia
being invented by the Muslim Brotherhood
first of all so what if it was but but
what they're trying to say is that you
know we should be scared of them we
should we should have this fear of
what's going on this is a complete you
know this is a hoax basically someone
came up with this random idea
Islamophobia is a term that's been used
for a hundred years yeah one of its
earliest appearances was used in a book
written about the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him we in French so in 1918 they
were using the term Islamophobia in
French throughout the 20s throughout the
30s I started to become more prevalent
in the 70s and the 80s and specifically
after September 11th and with you know
rising Islamophobia that came out this
is so basic fact-checking that he could
have gone he could have gone - and I'm
not even advertised website Robert
Spencer is a guy who hates Muslims to
the core he's like Matt that like that
the king of Islamophobes basically this
guy had to come out with an article
saying look guys we shouldn't make this
argument because it has absolutely no
basis whatsoever so if there was
fact-checking going on and I hope you
know he goes back in double Texas this
is just a false theory so we shouldn't
just keep throwing out all these red
herrings which are which are false is to
distract people you know away from the
topic yeah and that's not that's not
being intellectually approaching the
topic and it's not being genuine and I
think I think Joe I mean I hope that
this you know gets to him
we know some of the same people also add
and I hope that he can he can take a
turn towards the better and be more
genuine and covering this because it's
something that that does like you said
affect the lives of so many people so
many people have because of the Salama
phobia the hate machine mosques are
being burned down people are being
killed leaders in the Chicago area
demand a hate crime investigation after
three Muslim students were killed in
North Carolina this week the students
were shot in the head Tuesday at their
apartment complex it's a very disturbing
note fill with hate was found next to
her at 11:15 in the morning the teen
walks into the family Sky View Street
home to find two things
evidence of some kind of break-in in the
rear of the home and her mother in a
pool of blood on the dining room floor
next to her mother she says is a hateful
note to the effect of go back to your
native country several US cities
investigations are underway into
possible hate crimes against Muslims
DeMarco Morgan is following this
surveillance video shows a suspect
punching kicking and stomping on a
Muslim teenager in Brooklyn New York
the beating took place outside a mosque
during a midnight prayer service graphic
pictures show how badly the teen and his
friend were beaten the mosque is urging
police to investigate the attack as a
hate crime one of the victims says the
attacker called him a terrorist as he
kicked him in Minneapolis police are
also investigating the recent shooting
of two Muslim men as a possible hate
crime this weekend authorities in
Florida arrested 25-year old Taylor
Anthony Basanti in connection with the
beating of a man outside the same mosque
Orlando nightclub shooter omar medina
being killed you know it's we've got hit
jobs are being written off
I mean violence is escalating and I'm
sure he doesn't want to be contributing
to that yeah let's go on